florence noël 79 ans connaît les camions
et l'ont conduit depuis près de 60 ans
la mère 57e année sur les heroes mais
avant j'ai fait de la shoah négocie on
avait des contrats de déneigement la
municipalité
chaque jour de la semaine elles
transportent du gravier du concassé du
sable de la terre est aujourd'hui de
l'asv'olt elle est en forme là mais
problème le chd en santé je crois pas
tenu longtemps
le d'habitude je touche à dubeau a
dissout pas que ça ait le nom est en
parfaite santé chanceuse en fallait que
ma première petite tomate felipe son
jeune frère de 74 ans il est aussi
camionneurs il est très fier de sa
grande soeur est heureux de travailler
souvent avec elle est parfaite le camion
un peu
[Musique]
la star est vraiment à droite avec un
camion à tour été demain aîné d'une
famille de 19 ans florence a toujours
travaillé sur
leur
travail avant de faire montrer y ait des
vaches et avant d'aller à l'école puis
on renaît détracteurs puis je vais
amener les bidons comme j'avais 7 ans je
faisais avec rétro aux milles avec un
tracteur pour aller porter un crime avec
placer concevait pas les deux prêtent
bidons de lait connu de tous les
camionneurs de la région de magog elle
est respectée de tous auger regatta
travaillant elle a pu en faire leur
alyah de pau à l'arrêt de paul à peu le
samedi s'ils vont demander pour le
travail et envoya les voyais aller le
dimanche aussi pu les soirs à 10 k le
plein des ouvrages après la maison
l'ifla les plates-bandes illégaux sont
bien gentils
jeudi devait rester chez eux plus
vieilles de toulouse
c'est vrai il ya dans mon association
des camionneurs je suis la plus fière de
toute la gamme de camions qu'elle
conduit et usagers plus jeunes elles en
auraient acheté un oeuf l'usagé ce pour
toujours la femme parce que des fois tu
atteins qui va être meilleur que soft
met de l'argent dedans
elle a donc toujours son métier et veut
le faire encore pendant quelques années
c'est sur jard hype florence noël est la
preuve que la passion du travail n'a pas
d'âge ici jean arel radio canada et au
stif